Probleme benennen damit man sie lösen
kann das machen wir immer seltener das
sagen sie Frau Schröter und da sind wir
auch schon mittendrin in ihrem Thema
Probleme offen benennen offen sprechen
ja setze ich mal gleich an an das Thema
was wir eben hatten Silvester ja
darf man danach fragen welchen
Hintergrund diejenigen hatten die
randaliert haben die die
Sicherheitskräfte auch die Sanitäter
angegriffen haben ist das stadthaft oder
ist das rassistisch wie ja viele
Vertreter linker Organisationen und auch
Parteien gesagt haben darf man nach dem
Migrationshintergrund fragen darf man
ihn benennen oder fällt das unter den
Bereich Tabu und womit ich mich
beschäftige ist die zunehmende
Tabuisierung von
Themen die umstritten sind ja wir haben
ja viele Themen zu denen es
unterschiedliche und auch sehr
unterschiedliche Meinungen gibt
Migration ist eines dieser Themen
Islamismus wären anderes mit dem habe
ich mich lange lange Zeit beschäftigt
aber auch Klima Umwelt
Energieversorgung das sind alles Themen
zu denen kann man sehr unterschiedliche
Meinungen haben und was ich aber
zunehmend beobachte anstatt dass man
tatsächlich ein Tisch setzen sagt so und
wo sind da jetzt die Maximalposition und
wo treffen wir uns in der Mitte das
bestimmte Themen automatisch auf einer
tabu-liste landen
zum Beispiel das Thema Migration sie
finden an der Universität kaum noch
Forschungen zu den Schattenseiten von
Migration wenn Sie den Begriff
Parallelgesellschaft
Kultur Islamismus verwenden dann sind
sie kriegen sie keinen Forschungsgeld
dann sind sie sozusagen kaltgestellt
aber das betrifft ja nicht nur
Wissenschaft des betrifft auch die ganz
mit der Bevölkerung ich stelle immer
wieder fest dass Leute sagen darf ich
das jetzt eigentlich noch sagen habe ich
jetzt den falschen Begriff verwendet ist
das ein Thema wo mich vielleicht jetzt
jemand als Nazi beschimpft oder als
Rassist beschimpft oder als Transport
oder es gibt so ein paar
Begrifflichkeiten die wo Menschen schon
unsicher sind und in der Tat ich
beobachte das ja als Wissenschaftlerin
es gibt ganze Abhandlungen was man alles
nicht mehr sagen darf und was man
stattdessen sagen darf das nicht nur das
Gendern das ja bei den meisten Leuten
doch Emotionen hervorruft sondern es
sind auch viele andere Dinge
Abkürzung von Wörtern die die ersetzt
werden auch im migrationskontext ja wie
oft hat sich der Begriff für Flüchtling
verändert von Asylbewerber zu
Flüchtlingen zu geflüchtete zu Schutz
suchen damit sind wir alles ideologische
Konzepte verbunden und das muss man
einfach wissen damit beschäftige ich
mich und das wenn man da tiefer
einsteigt dann merkt man da gibt es das
Konzepte die sind außerordentlich
bedenklich ja bedenklich nämlich weil
die Vorstellung existiert in einigen
Köpfen auch der Linken Politiker aber
auch Wissenschaftler und Kultur
schaffender dass die westliche
Gesellschaft von Grund auf rassistisch
sein von Grund auf eigentlich etwas
verbesserungswürdig ist
und dass die Aufgabe jetzt der Politik
aber auch der Bildungsinstitution darin
besteht dem Westlern und vor allem den
weißen es geht immer nur um weiß es gibt
tatsächlich einen Bereich der nennt sich
critical Wildnis studies das heißt wir
forschen kritisch überweis sein den
weißen ihren Rassismus auszutreiben mit
dem sie geboren sind da gibt es
tatsächlich die Idee man sei damit
geboren und der Begriff den sie bestimmt
alle schon gehört haben lautet
struktureller Rassismus das heißt in der
Struktur der Gesellschaft in den
Institutionen in der Politik in der
Bildungseinrichtung auch natürlich in
den Organen des Staates besonders in der
Polizei da ist der Rassismus sozusagen
tief verankert und jetzt sind einige
Gutmenschen
woke die sich selber als wach bezeichnen
sind jetzt aufgerufen der Gesellschaft
den Spiegel vorzuhalten und dafür zu
sorgen dass sie ihren Rassismus erkennen
und dazu gehört dann letztendlich auch
das Programm der
Umwandlung der Gesellschaft durch das
Erkennen dann bestimmte Maßnahmen
aufzulegen dass sich da etwas ändert und
da sind wir bei diesem Bogen
Sprachregelung da sind wir bei den
Tabuthemen bestimmte Dinge dürfen nicht
mehr angesprochen werden weil sie als
Ausdruck des Rassismus bezeichnet werden
bestimmte Wörter dürfen nicht mehr
verwendet werden und die Liste der
Wörter wird immer länger also wer da
wirklich sensibel ist der hat schon
Angst das merke ich immer wieder auch
bei Kollegen tatsächlich
hat schon Angst tatsächlich Sätze zu
formulieren weil irgendjemand wieder
kommen könnte könnte sagen dann das geht
jetzt gar nicht und letztendlich
läuft die Gesellschaft weil viele
natürlich aussteigen wer kann also nur
Akademiker die sich aus Berufswegen
damit beschäftigen sind überhaupt up to
date dass sie wissen was ist jetzt alles
auf der schwarzen Liste und auf der
weißen Liste äh letztendlich führt es
natürlich dazu dass ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung aussteigt aus dieser ganzen
Debatte und sagt ich kann mich da gar
nicht mehr artikulieren ich weiß noch
gar nicht mehr in welchen Worten ich
meine Kritik fassen soll und ein anderer
Teil ja zieht das einfach durch das
Ergebnis meiner Meinung nach ist
gespaltene Gesellschaft und wenn wir
wissen wollen wohin das führen kann dann
brauchen wir bloß Nachbarländer
anzuschauen indem wir große Rechte
Bewegungen haben und USA beispielsweise
wo die Gesellschaft tatsächlich in zwei
Teile zerfallen ist und ich denke wir
sollten alles tun damit für sowas
verhindern heransauer benutzen sie Worte
die sie vielleicht von zehn Jahren
benutzt haben jetzt nicht mehr und
können Sie sich auch damit anfreunden
dass man jetzt zum Beispiel Gebärende
Person sagt und nicht Mutter ist ihnen
das geläufig oder ist Ihnen das völlig
fremd also das ist eine zweiteilige
Frage zum letzteren Teil
kann ich nur sagen ich kann mich
überhaupt nicht damit anfreunden und zum
ersten Teil Ihrer Frage ich rede und
spreche heute so wie vor zehn Jahren
ich habe mich nie verbiegen lassen und
bin immer gut damit gefahren und ich
glaube jetzt komme ich zum dritten Mal
noch mal zurück zur Frage Bodenhaftung
haben Politiker noch Bodenhaftung also
ich höre täglich in meinen Wahlkreis
hinein 280.000 Menschen ja die würden
mich vom Hof jagen politisch gesehen
wenn ich auf einmal anpasslerisch
wirkmäßig und ähm
betreiben würde und das tue ich nicht
ich rede heute so wie immer und jetzt
auch immer Ton Frau Schröter sagte
gerade sie glaubt das könnte zu einer
Spaltung der Gesellschaft führen sie
gehen glaube ich auch so weit die sagen
würden da da ist fast die Demokratie
schon in Gefahr gehen sie auch soweit
teilen Sie diesen Gedanken heilvoll und
ganz
wenn wir die und breite Unterstützung in
der Bevölkerung verlieren
irgendwo sucht sich das dann einen
Ausweg um die Wähler Zahlen sind danach
irgendwo Heilmittel Stimmzettel und ich
meine die Grundlage was ist die
Grundlage der Demokratie auch historisch
gesehen die Meinungsfreiheit die
Pressefreiheit die Kunstfreiheit
Freiheitsrechte ja also die
Freiheitsrechte sind die Grundlage der
Demokratie wenn wir die einschränken
dann verlieren wir ein Stück weit der
freie Bürger der freie Bürger ist im
Grundgesetz das ist das Subjekt dieses
Staates wenn wir aber jetzt anfangen die
Leute in Gruppen Einzelteil das ist auch
ein Teil des Programms es gibt die
Tätergruppen und es gibt die
Opfergruppen die Opfer sind Minderheiten
je nachdem wer sich gerade mit guter
Unterstützung als Minderheit
positionieren kann hat dann ein
Opferstatus Täter sind immer weiß aber
nicht nur das weil trifft nun mal auch
mehr also weißt du wahrscheinlich nicht
so sehr trocken ist auch eine
Hierarchisierung ein weißer Mann ist
schon mehr Täter als eine weiße Frau ein
heterosexueller Mann noch mehr ein alter
heterosexueller Mann das sozusagen der
Moderne Anti-Christ ja ihre Partei wurde
bei der letzten Bundestagswahl vor allem
von jungen Leuten gewählt sagen na klar
muss ich Sprache verändern klar müssen
wir uns da weiterentwickeln sagen sie
gebärender Mensch statt Mutter tun Sie
persönlich sich da vielleicht noch
schwer wollen sie sich daran gewöhnen
und können es nicht oder gehen Sie das
ab
in ihrem Beitrag wo haben sie ja auch
auf ein Problem hingewiesen gerade was
davon gesellschaftlich ausgeht die Frage
ob wir
überhaupt noch Grautöne zulassen in der
Debatte ob wir wir zeichnen in vielen
Stellen nur noch Schwarz und Weiß und
ich glaube dass wir gerade wenn wir die
Demokratie wieder stärken wollen wenn
wir verhindern wollen dass extreme stark
werden sowohl am rechten als auch am
linken Rand da bin ich bei einem
Ramsauer müssen wir in dieser unserer
Zeit das zulassen dass man miteinander
diskutiert das macht unsere Demokratie
stark dass man Position und Meinung hat
und dass man sich die Position und
Meinung des anderen auch anhört dass man
sie auch bis einem gewissen Maße erträgt
auch das gehört dazu und daraus sich
etwas entwickelt damit wir eben nicht
immer mehr an Politikverdrossenheit
erleben und das beste Beispiel für mich
ist das politische Handeln innerhalb der
corona-pandemie wo wir vieles nicht mehr
politisch erklären konnten und probiert
wurde vieles abzutun entweder bis zu der
für oder dagegen aber es gab nichts
dazwischen in der Frage kann man nicht
vielleicht doch Freiheitsgrundrechte und
Gesundheitsschutz in Einklang bringen
die Debatte war in einer gewissen Phase
überhaupt nicht zugänglich oder erlaubt
und da haben wir ja statistisch ganz
klar hinterlegt bekommen dass das ein
großen Absatz einen großen weglauf an
Vertrauen von Politik gemacht hat mit
den Menschen wo Gerichte Entscheidung
korrigiert haben weil der Plenarsaal
außer Kraft gesetzt wurde und nur noch
Regierung ist immer wieder zurück in der
Pandemie ich wollte mal über die Sprache
reden
weil das ist der Kern um den es für mich
hier geht ähm und das ist das ist
wichtig ich werde Mutter sagen wenn Sie
darauf hin wenn jemand sagt wenn jemand
sagen möchte Gebärende denn soll er das
sagen
dann soll er das sagen so aber
gewährende gebären und das ist keine
Kategorie denn ich sage
Gebärenden gebären nur in einem ganz
bestimmten Augenblick ihres Lebens und
ansonsten sind sie keine Gebärenden
gebären sind im Moment des Gebärens eine
Gebärende Person das ist von
US-Präsident Joe Biden er hat das so
eingeführt völliger
falls man Frauen damit meinen sollte es
gibt viele die gebären nie ja und das
Gebärende ist ein aktiver Vorgang der
auch nach dem gebären ganz schnell
abgeschlossen ist gut auch kinderlose
Frauen aber sie wird am Kabinettstisch
gesendet ja da sitzen sie jetzt nicht
aber ihre Partei Kollegen sitzen da mit
den Grünen mit der SPD am Tisch
vielleicht auch meine SMS sie tauschen
sich aus wie läuft es da ab
also ich rede auch von Berlinerinnen und
Berlinern aber dass man nicht richtig
geändert so das könnte man jetzt auch
schon als Gendern beschreiben aber ich
sage nur noch okay immer verstehst so
aber ich sage in der in in der Breite
wie sie ist jetzt hier ausgeführt haben
tue ich es selber mache ich es auch
nicht und
insoweit ich kann ihn wirklich nicht
sagen wie am Kabinettstisch gesprochen
wird ich bin nicht regierungsmittel die
Frage kann ich ihn nicht beantworten die
stellen sie mal jemand in der nächsten
Sendung wenn jemand aus dem
Bundeskabinett ist uns gerade so
eindringlich aus ihrem Leben geschildert
wenn sie jetzt so eine Diskussion hören
muss auch um tiefere Probleme aber eben
auch um diese kleinen Feinheiten der
Sprache geht sagen sie da verliert man
mich jetzt völlig ist mir doch total
egal ob jetzt jemand gendert oder
gebärend oder Mutter oder in oder ein
Sternchen das kann
Lebensrealität drin und die Freundschaft
also es wird mir ja vorgegeben ne also
wenn ich jetzt ein Mann es gibt abgeben
würde beim Verlag wo beendet wird das
würden die gerne Strucken also von daher
ist es natürlich eine Problematik die
mich sehr sehr betrifft an der Stelle
und das ist tatsächlich so ja also da
wird schon sehr viel Wert darauf gelegt
und
wir haben ja sowieso haben wir ja
sowieso und das ist ja auch so ein
bisschen ich bekomme oft gesagt wir
haben ja noch die Meinungsfreiheit in
Deutschland du kannst ja deine Meinung
äußern und dann sage ich immer ja aber
Meinungsfreiheit heißt solange ich mich
auf den Boden der Rechtstaatlichkeit
bewege dass ich meine Meinung äußern
kann und muss keine Konsequenz
befürchten und das ist nicht mehr der
Fall und ich habe das noch nicht wieder
gesehen ich habe auf Facebook hatte ich
eine Erlebnis kurzgeschildert ich war
auf dem Friedhof und habe da das gerade
von meinem Bruder gemacht und wollte
gehen und da war eine Frau und die sagt
hallo Entschuldigung könnten sie noch
ein bisschen bleiben und Sache brauchen
sie Hilfe sagt sie hat so Angst ja sie
ist schon zweimal fast überfallen worden
ja so und
hat mir eben erzählt es waren
offensichtlich Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund und sie hat Angst
und ob ich bleiben könnte und ich habe
gesagt guten habe sie dann das
grabfertig machen lassen und hatte
darüber auf Facebook dann einfach nur
geschrieben hat weil mich das so
beschäftigt hat auch das ist von
Facebook gelöscht worden ja es war meine
Erfahrung ne also